these people feel marginalized by the
new regime and they're making their
anger loud and clear their demands
haven't changed since the July 3rd qu
they want former President Mohammed
Morsi reinstated when the march reached
the Ministry of Defense it was stopped
by security forces once again the Muslim
Brotherhood has failed to make headway
we are the ones who will free Egypt if
the military is using tanks to stop
women and children what will they do to
the men meanwhile the transitional
government is looking to strengthen its
position its appointed a committee of
legal experts to revise the country's
constitution the change is made will go
to a referendum it's seen as a vital
step on the path to new elections the
interim Prime Minister Hazem al-beblawi
hazards reconciliation and an end to the
unrest gossamer well are you the country
is divided but we cannot continue with
these divisions the first goal for any
government in a situation like this is a
return to harmony differences are
inevitable de la fere cos 0 but at this
stage both sides appear to have dug
their heels in once again the streets of
Egypt have become a battleground